six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
from the sixty-three area code caller
from six to three welcome tell me who
you are and what's on your mind today
hi my name is Matthew I'm from Arizona
where I have a very general question I
don't really have a specific example but
my question is why doesn't a head of any
of the 15 government departments be held
accountable for doing the opposite of
something that they said that they will
won't do in their confirmation hearing
your okay so let me see if I you're
saying there are people who run
government departments now who said they
would do certain things during their
confirmation hearings and they haven't
done them and you want to know why
they're not being held accountable yeah
or that they did the exact opposite of
what they said that they would do
because that's how politics works
unfortunately I mean it's I wish I had a
better answer but that's that's exactly
how these things work I mean look at the
President of the United States he's done
the opposite of so many things he said
that he would do and campaigned on doing
just this is why politics has become so
toxic and corrosive in the United States
because not only do they lie all the
time there's no consequences and the
consequences are often more linked to
things like likability or personal
scandals or whatever the case may be I
mean it's it's unfortunate but that
that's why this is what we're dealing
with right is there not awaits
is there not a way to hold them
accountable is there not a I mean
besides voting but on the voting right I
mean it's so so Donald Trump selected
these people if you believe that he is
not holding them accountable then you've
got to hold him accountable and vote him
out and that is the most direct that's
the most direct way that our system
allows for holding these people
accountable and it's not happening
people vote against their own beliefs
and they don't hold politicians
accountable for the promises they make
it's it's sad but that's what we have
okay so that while they're in office
well actually we don't vote for these
government heads so we can't vote them
out right so you have to hold the person
who selected them accountable
you know you know thank you for the call
appreciate I mean depressing depressing
reality but it is it is what we're
dealing with